لازم تغزي
حالك هناك جمله كانت في خطابي نتامل في
يوم من الايام نحن اطفال قطاع غزه وطلاب
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين وطلاب الفلسطينيين
بشكل عام ان نستيقظ يوما ما بتفاؤل وليس
بخوف اليوم نح نستيقظ بخوف المره هي دورنا
على البيت ما
لقينا انا الدكتور مروان ابو دقه والد
المصاب احمد مروان بدقه ام احمد واحمد
كانوا يعني في مشوار وجايين اي
هم في جيتهم كان استهداف قد تم فحنا
التمينا كنا يعني على يعني مكان ياينا من
الضربه هذ مكان يكون بعيد عن الضربه فاحمد
تحرك من مكاننا وقرب شويه يعني انه يطل
يشوف البيت واش صار فيه واللي كنا فيه
وكان مع واحد صاحبه الا اسمنا الصاروخ
الثاني انا يعني مش مستوعب انه كان احمد
بعيد عني انا كنت حاطه قدامي الا طلع زي
هيك لقيته ايش استلق على الارض وكان في
ضيه داخله في رجله وعامله كسر في الرجل
اليمنى اجا الشباب اللي كانوا قراب منه
اجوا يسعفه ضربوا الصاروخ الثالث اللي هو
كان ايش صاو الباقي الشباب اللي كانوا
بدهم
يساعدو زياد ط زياط نلعب بسطين جيب الب
انا الطفله الفلسطيني احمد مروان ابو ذقه
انا عمري 15 عاما احمد قبل الحرب كان سفير
لاجئي فلسطين في الامم المتحده لعام 2023
في شهر 6 العام الجاري طبعا كان ل مشاركات
سابقه في البرلمانات الطلابيه وكانت لغتي
العربيه والانجليزيه قويتان كان لي حضور
في عده يعني منها ورشه عمل في الاردن وعده
يعني لقاءات اخرى مع طلبه من الخارج
البانيين واسبان ف عندما سمعت خبر ترشيحي
يعني طبعا مث يعني مثل اي شخص يسمع فرصه
جميله في حياته سيكون يعني فرحا مسرورا
يعني يوم كنت يعني جدا سعيد بعدها اخبروني
بانني تم القبول على اسمي وطلبوا اجراءات
السفر والاوراق وما الى ذلك وتخطيط الخطاب
الخطاب انا كتبته
بيدي احمد ابو
د محمود درويش يعني نتصور بان بانني كنت
واضع خطه
لحياتي ان شاء الله ولكن بعد هذه الحرب
والتهجير ثم صابه طبعا انا اصبت في منزل
نزحنا اليه حتى في اول اسبوعين لم اكن
استطيع الحركه من
الفراش احمد اصبح حلمه هو كيف سيعود للمشي
مره اخرى اصبح يعني تفكير عقله كله في
التحويله كيف سيسافر الخارج من اجل يعني
استكمال علاجه احمد اصبح يفكر هل سيستطيع
المشي على قدمه مثل ما كان في السابق مره
اخرى احمد اصبح يفكر حاليا فقط في النجاه
لا